des signatures aussi appelé des tags
pour des appartements les commerces ou
des infrastructures publiques montréal
en est tapissé
les murs de cette mosquée sont
fréquemment vandalisés
omar derby en sait quelque chose c'est
lui qui gère l'édifice
mais benneteau rick yune comme magnum
les graffiteurs reviendrons d'ici deux
semaines selon lui on voit réveiller la
peinture
moi personnellement ça fait quelques
fois que je viens ici
parce que ce sont des graffitis campaign
spot
à montréal le service de nettoyage de
graffitis et gratuit est géré par chaque
arrondissement
en une quarantaine de minutes le mur est
complètement nettoyé
vandalisme pour certains dollar pour
d'autres
je pense que pour apprécier cette fois à
7 le tag je pense que tu dois être une
personne très sympathique
pour l'artiste mathieu qui adore faire
des graffitis illégaux est une manière
pour des jeunes issus de milieux plus
difficile d'exprimer leur créativité
sans filtre ce que fait un tag beau pour
moi c'est les histoires en arrière je
peux voir un tag d'un artiste de los
angeles qui étaient là pendant deux
semaines dans 2000 eur j c'est encore là
qui sait les jambes qui a pété partout
dans le monde moi je sais ça mais le
personne normale c'est juste notre
taille fait
l'italie coûts ont contribué au
développement de nombreux exercices et
les amis dans le collectif qui font des
murales incroyable dans cette ville que
tout le monde apprécie le villa aucune
idée que cette même personne a fait ces
tags que dans tes yeux c'est juste une
autre tâche
au début de la pandémie les signalements
pour les graffitis ont augmenté
particulièrement dans les quartiers
centraux
et ailleurs veulent visible donc pas
pour rien qu'ils s'en vont au
centre-ville puis vont au 10e étage puis
met une grosse affaire au point qu'ils
vont sur l'échangeur turcot parce qu'ils
savent que non seulement on la laisse
souvent
l'échangeur turcot et nettoyer deux fois
par annie l'an dernier 22 mille mètres
carrés de graffitis ont été enlevés là
on joue la population parfois ils se
rendent pas compte qu'on le fait le
nettoyage on n'est pas assez parce que
quelques jours après que deux semaines
au plus tard les graphes tom vont
revenir le nettoyage peut prendre une
demi journée pour un secteur donné si le
graffiti sur la structure massa mais
c'est sur une fermeture temporaire ses
pertes sur leurs lieux que la fin de
semaine avec des équipes spécialisées
signalement sa demande vraiment d'aller
chercher plusieurs personnes depuis
janvier 2022 les maris à défense et 338
milles dollars pour nettoyer les
graffitis
rosemont la petite patrie 121 mille
dollars
dans le plateau mont royal le budget
annuel pour 2022 prévoit 6 187 milles
dollars un montant trois fois plus élevé
qu'en 2019 on aurait jamais de sucre sur
la rive sur les souris graffiti parce
que c'est un phénomène qui va toujours
exister à mon avis mais on arrive
d'avoir à avoir un certain contrôle
l'opposition officielle voudrait que la
ville adopte une manière uniforme pour
la gestion des graffitis actuellement la
ville chaque arrondissement il fait
comme il veut une ville qui se respecte
doit au moins donner les guides une
façon de faire à ses arrondissements et
doit surtout mettre l'argent nécessaire
pour mathieu kadosh très prime id est
facile est loin d'être la solution c'est
beaucoup plus complexe que ça effacer
les résultats de ces histoires là ce
sera pas ça va pas préparer le situation
de saint jacques on a besoin de
organisme intégré dans le communiqué que
aide à cette gêne pas de trouver les
réseaux qui a besoin
pour certains l'argent pour nettoyer les
graffitis devrait être investi ailleurs
pour d'autres la ville tarde à nettoyer
les graffitis ligot
mais il est difficile voire impossible
d'encadrer l'art urbain c'est ce qui en
fait son essence
[Musique]